all right well I mean like the point
that I wanted to make this is a two
minute clip so let's just watch it we're
sort of throw some commentary on it but
I mean like this is a you know people
are always asking for feedback on like
current events and like you know what's
going on with business sort of stuff and
this is your typical
you know beta male soy boy with a gut
and man tits and you know goofball sort
of thing and he's trying to sell you
like the dream of I'm Gonna Save the
World and he hasn't even you know saved
himself and become the best version of
himself so let's just check this out but
Sam is not a traditional billionaire
Because he believes in the concept did
you guys ever see this guy's girlfriend
by the way no I need to see it okay
unfortunately let's lead with that I'm
gonna go one or two ways right uh okay
you guys want to lead with his
girlfriend over under over under on if
she's hot or not I'm gonna say yes he
has a billion dollars I'm gonna say yes
I remember Eric uh dropped the dropped
the image over and um he was like you
know this guy's worth two billion
dollars and he's hitting this
uh hang on let's see if I can find a
picture she needs to be sent to
Ukrainian boot camp
see a truck stop hooker or something or
like she super smashed out uh hang on a
second you know like you know just to
sort of like you know frame you know who
the guy is uh sure screen window Chrome
okay so this is guys worth two billion
dollars and this is what he's had
all right so it's like a Pixar character
ah well you know I guess you know you
every every pot has its lid you know
sort of thing right they definitely met
playing some video game somewhere yeah
oh for sure more than likely uh okay so
let's go back to this to this clip here
of our buddy Sam and his little little
Scamp is not a traditional billionaire
Because he believes in the concept of
earn to give which means his goal as a
human is to make as much money as
possible just to give it away earn to
give and that's exactly what he's doing
so say that you have a hundred dollars
and you want to figure out dude sounds
like he's got the T level of like a 13
year old girl with that vocal tone what
you can do with it to help the world
Ernie to give is thinking about which
causes which charity saves the most
lives per dollar this hundred dollars
can go as far as they possibly can to
help the world last year this 29 year
old guy don't what did he what did he
rip everybody off for again wasn't it to
the tune of billions
the FTX exchange yeah uh the garbageman
explained to me that I met apparently
it's just like they raised all this fake
money
uh I don't know it well enough and then
it just they went bankrupt that was your
you're you're like big in the crypto
space what's your take on it
um what they did is that they grew
through an investment from binance and
then they bit the hand that fed them the
mechanism through which they collapsed
the market is that they
um couldn't like they had their own
token which is called ftt
and they pump that up but because they
could not monetize it by selling it they
um loaned against it so the liquidity
issue
yeah so what they did is that they put
the the funds that they took us alone in
Alameda research to use it for uh
Trading
for uh further
um raising the price of FTP and doing
some other [ __ ] and this is how they
basically leveraged themselves
we needed 50 million dollars next year
he is planning to donate 500 million
dollars a year and next decade he will
probably give away more than 10 billion
dollars
[Music]
the amount of good that you can do uh
for the future of the world is is really
large and it's way more than you can do
to actually make yourself happy with
anything like that amount of money and
he is funding everything you can think
of global warming it's one of the
biggest problems that we have to tackle
together as a world carbon 19
preparedness we have to be ready for the
next pandemic look at him sitting there
with a mask in his hand like I'll tell
you right now anybody that's gullible
enough to have fallen for this after the
evidence became clear within 90 to 120
days that it wasn't that big of a deal
it's just I mean you just can't trust
these people neglected tropical diseases
more than a billion people suffer from
them we have to eliminate these diseases
and of course Animal Welfare animals
deserve to live just like we do
soy milk in the background did you see
that of course there you go you've got
soy milk in there oh yeah
it's also why I'm vegan and look at all
that juice pure sugar
also wine vegan Sam doesn't need the
money to buy a Lamborghini or to buy a
Rolex or to impress his friends in fact
his car is a Toyota Corolla wow so
strong and brave come on where's your
car
so that one there that's like what a
Toyota why do these guys always have
backpacks on I've always I've always
wondered that like what do you keep in
the backpack that you have to walk
around with all the time for the for
these for these video clips
I don't know I can't take Corolla why
don't you buy a Lamborghini man it
didn't have any particular need for one
he wants to well you don't have any need
for one if you don't have nuts right
to get rich in order to impact the world
and change it
but wow okay well there you go that's
you know I don't know do you guys trust
guys like this because I because I've
never thrown money at people like this
it just it just doesn't make any sense
to me I would not give that guy my money
for anything I I think he's full of [ __ ]
I always look for season you do his job
was that drugs I would trust him to do
his job if he was employed to do those
that was worth I I I definitely drink a
Starbucks coffee if you make it for me
and she eats the tits nicely yeah I'm
sure he's got I'm sure he's got great
coffee making skills so he can always
you know figure out something to do but
maybe one day I'll run into him at a
Starbucks
of you you ran away with his private
private jet to Argentina I think oh is
that what happened he actually fled
and yeah and there's this uh discussion
that the hack that's happening right now
on FTX is from an Insider and it's
actually uh supported by him
oh yeah actually that's right I just saw
something from Nick on that hold on
um there's an article apparently this is
going to Tumble further
yeah the exchange went bankrupt and they
had more liabilities than they had
um
equity
but they still had some money in The
Exchange and now it was halfway and also
drawn by uh Bahamian citizens
and now the whole exchange is at zero so
so this article was just posted nine
minutes ago or sorry nine minutes before
we launched So within the last 20
minutes uh title says FTX is
investigating a potential hack amid
bankruptcy filings more than 400 million
worth of crypto funds appear to be
missing
um about 600. that's not good for the
market that is kind of probably forced
to Tumble a little further hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out